[Music]
every new watch is like a new piece of
Arts it has a different story to tell
[Music]
some very interesting things about
watches on the one hand you have a high
precision device and the other thing is
they have to be hand finish which is
very related to arts and crafts you have
these two words in one watch both the
esthetical aspect of it and the
mechanical aspect of it here we are at
Anolon sun and our premises in the short
form where we manufacture all our
watches Arnold and Sun refers to John
Arnold who was one of the biggest and
most important watchmaker who ever lived
he invented a lot of technical solutions
still in use today the aim of the modern
company to innovate and to continues
legacy but in a contemporary new manner
the idea is really to continue the story
more than to repeating it first with the
design team we design house what should
look like the size it should have the
thickness you have to have a kind of
mechanical harmony it is good looking or
not and one we are happy with the new
complications and we think the watch has
something news then we create basically
the inner works which will make the
aesthetic happen the first thing you
have to do is to order the right
material because we use a lot of
different materials into mechanical
movement going from brass over steel up
to titanium or gold and you need a
specific material for every different
part of it
[Applause]
once you have the raw material you start
will be making the components we have
different kind of raw materials go into
different workshops for depending on the
part you want to make if you want to do
watchmaking on super high level you need
extremely skilled and specifically
trained people we are more than studying
different job description purely
different education and you find these
education these training only in this
region because nowhere else in the world
you need such kind of know-how working
with tiny parts is a challenge because
tiny parts makes very small tolerances
we are working in micron tolerances so
you cannot do anything with a good
tuning we have in-house tool making
Department which makes from the little
screwdrivers wash maker needs up to a
stamping tool which takes months of
development so the reason why we do our
tuning in-house because if you are not
mastering your tools
you're not mastering the part you want
to produce
once all the parts are cut with
machinery they go to be cleaned just
submitted to quality control who decides
if the part is good or not to continue
to the decoration of workshop
different kind of traditional movement
decorations are plied from Geneva strive
sateen finish depending on the component
is a mechanical watch you buy today is
not the leading technology anymore it's
really crafted out you are not racing
for technological breakthrough you are
more racing for making more spectacular
work shows build a very different
relation to a mechanical version you do
to an electronic device because the day
you buy it you know that the next one
will come and that you will swap it to
getting the better one with the
mechanical watch it's really the object
as a physical object of all the handwork
which make it special and unique that
makes I think a big difference to
something more the electronic side once
these parts have been decorated their
quality checked again to see if the
decoration hasn't affect the functional
aspect of it it's always a bit of a
trick you have to decorate with not to
deteriorate the path they go to be
preassembled in a specific workshop
before going to the watchmakers set
stones for instance in two main plates
put axes on two wheels and once all
these parts have been preassembled they
arrived to watchmaker who does the final
assembly the watchmaker gets all the
little parts in little boxes start
taking the main plate which is a base on
everything gets build on adding the
wheels which are all on axes put
different bridges holding all different
wheels in place you have to add all the
winding mechanism because you want to be
able to warn you are put a dial on it
then you put hands and one last thing
which we aren't always at the end is the
escapement which is basically the heart
of any mechanical watch it's also what
you hear when you're listening to a
mechanical watch when you have the Tic
Tac it's a very first time you will see
and here you watch moving
[Music]
starting from the simple beating it's a
long process going to a highly accurate
mechanical watch you cannot just put the
parts together and expect the watch to
tell perfect time we are checking the
watches or 600 hours on different
vibration and other machines to get
really sure that everything is okay and
adjust a little tiny dust you don't see
it when you put it all together but when
you move the watch it kind of files off
the movement now this process is pretty
really long but this is what's a
complexity of such a mechanical device
requests once you see that the accuracy
of the movement is good you put it into
a watch case which we protect the
movement you add the bracelet and the
backup and you have a watch watches are
most of the time perceived as a time
capsule it's really something which are
still built today as it used to be for
the last centuries it's nice I think
also for people to be able to buy
something which has always existed and
there probably will always exist as a
form of art
[Music]
you